MARIS: But anyway,
it's my great pleasure
to have Steve here at Google.
Steve is an author,
business columnist
and behavioral expert, and
coauthor of "The New York
Times," "Wall Street
Journal," and "Business Week
International" best seller
"Yes, 50 Scientifically Proven
Ways to be Persuasive,"
which to date has
sold over a half
a million copies
and has been translated
into 26 languages.
Steve's current book,
"The Small Big,"
has been published
worldwide this month,
and is available on Amazon.
Steve speaks about the science
of influence and persuasion
and its application to a
wide variety of business,
government, and nonprofit
organizations around the world.
As well as an extensive
list of corporate clients,
Steve has worked
with the UK Cabinet
Office and the Behavioral
Change Network Team
with the UK
Department of Health.
He's guest lecturer on
senior executive programs
at the London Business
School, Cass Business School,
Oxford-- is it Said?
Said Business School, and
the Judge Business School
University of Cambridge, UK.
Steve regularly features in
the media, national press,
and online, including MSNBC,
BBC TV, and radio, "The New York
Times," and "Wired" magazine.
His monthly columns, including
the persuasion column
in the British Airways
in-flight magazine
and columns for the
Harvard Business Review,
are read by over 2.5
million people every month.
So please, a round of
applause, and join me
in welcoming Steve to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE: Well, thank you
very much indeed, Maris.
It's an absolute delight.
I'm just so happy to be
here and talk to a full room
here at Google this
afternoon about a subject
which I hope you'll find not
only super interesting but also
relevant to your roles.
One of the things I'd like to
be able to do this afternoon
is not just talk about the
theory of persuasion science
but talk about the practice
of influence and persuasion
as well, and specifically
how sometimes just making
very small changes to the
way that you make a case
or present a proposal
or request of someone
can oftentimes lead to
very big differences
in your persuasive success.
And so I'd like to talk a little
bit about that, and clearly
key to our new book,
"The Small Big."
But I thought I'd
start out actually
by telling you a story.
I love this story.
It concerns the late Lord Grade
of Elstree, a British peer,
who tells the story,
or used to tell
the story of a young man
who came to his office
one day seeking employment.
The story goes that Lord Lew
would be sitting at his desk,
smoking his fifth
Havana of the day.
It was, after all, around
7:30 in the morning.
And he, for a few
moments, stared menacingly
at this young man,
who was sitting
at the opposite
side of the desk,
before standing up and placing
on the desk between them
a large jug of water.
And then he looked at this
young man and he said,
young man, I've been told
you're quite the persuader.
So sell me this jug of water.
Undaunted, this
young man got up.
He went to the
corner of the room
where there was a waste paper
basket full to brimming.
He picked it up and
brought it back to the desk
and placed it next to the jug
of water and then lit a match,
dropped it into the
waste paper basket
and waited for a few moments
until the flames had reached
an impressive and perhaps
rather anxiety inducing level,
and then turned around
and said to the peer,
is his Lordship interested
in buying a jug of water?
Now the story's
entertaining, but I
think it's also instructive
when we think about influence
and persuasion, because
there are many approaches
that that young man
could have taken
to convince his counterpart.
He could have, for
example, provided
some information, or try
to sell this jug of water
by considering the
features and the benefits
of the jug of water.
He could have used
an economic argument,
and thought about how we might
provide some monetary incentive
or motivation in order
to persuade his audience.
But instead what he did
was pull on another lever
of the influence process, not
the informational motivation,
not the economic motivation,
but a change in context,
an environmental motivation.
That small shift,
which, incidentally,
if you think about
it, did nothing
to change what was on offer.
He simply made that small
shift in environment
that led to that
change in behavior.
And that's the
case that I'd like
to make when it comes to
influence and persuasion--
particularly successful
influence and persuasion.
Increasingly in this
information overloaded world
that we actually live in,
what we're finding now,
particularly these last two
decades of persuasion science,
is that contexts will
frequently trump cognitions
when it comes to successful
influence and persuasion.
And sometimes all
that requires you
to do as a communicator is to
make very small, often subtle
changes to the way that you
make a proposition or proposal
that link to deep
seated motivations
inherent in all of us.
In fact, one of the things that
this body of research suggests
is something rather surprising.
It's this idea that whilst
there may be many tens
of thousands of different ways
in which we can successfully
influence and persuade others
through the use of tactics
or changes, the vast majority
of most successful influence
and persuasion
can be categorized
in terms of just three
core motivations.
Those core motivations are
that, in this increasingly
information overloaded
world, we want
to make quick and
efficient decisions.
We want to also make decisions
in ways that affiliate us
with others and gain
the approval of others.
And finally, we want to
make decisions and behave
in ways that allow us
to be seen in the best
possible and positive light.
So the claim that I
have here, and the claim
that we make in this book, is
by thinking about influence
in the context of these
three core motivations
and aligning your
request, or your strategy,
or your proposal or
proposition to one or more
of these can significantly
enhance your success.
So I want to give you
a few examples and then
after we've done that, we'll
talk a little bit about how
we can apply these, and
maybe take a few questions.
So let's talk about the first.
This inherent motivation we
have to make accurate decisions
as efficiently and as
quickly as we possibly can.
What's kind of
interesting about this
is that oftentimes we
won't even consider
what is on offer in
order to do that.
Instead, what we do is
consider something--
an alternative, a comparison.
Let me give you an example.
How many of you like a glass
of wine maybe in the evenings
or weekends?
There's a fair
few number of you.
OK.
So consider the
humble wine list.
Typically when a
restaurant or a hotel bar
presents its wines
to its customers,
it does so in this way.
It starts with the house wine
at the top, and as you see,
as you look down the list
the wine increases in price.
This is familiar to you.
And typically what we find is
that when people are presented
with offers in this
way, they typically
pick those items
towards the top.
Not the cheapest, no one wants
to be a cheapskate after all.
So they'll take the second
or third ones on the list.
There's a small change that
any one bar, any hotel,
any restaurant could
make that significantly
alters the choices
that people make.
And it doesn't require
them to delete options.
It doesn't require them to
investing costly resources
or incentives these choices.
It simply requires them to
turn the list upside down.
And in that instance, these
now become more popular.
This is a really good
example I think of not only
a small change that
leads to a big difference
in this instance, but
also this idea of how
we use one stimulus,
one proposition
to make an accurate and
efficient decision about what
that right course
of action is next.
Now it turns out there's a
restaurant chain in Europe that
are taking this
one stage further.
And what they found
is that sometimes you
don't have to make what you
compare something to the same.
What's interesting about
the Carluccio's restaurant,
down here on the
bottom, left hand side.
The first thing when you open
a Carluccio's menu that you see
is a moterscooter.
You'll see it's priced
here at 2,771 pounds.
That's about $3 and
a half thousand.
There it is there.
Why would a restaurant
sell a moterscooter,
or attempt to sell a
moterscooter on its menu?
Well, it turns out
that it sure as hell
makes their salads and
sandwiches appear cheaper.
And that's the point
that we're making here.
Oftentimes you can change
people's perception
of the proposition you make,
change people's reaction
to your proposal,
not by doing anything
to change your proposal
at all, but instead,
by thinking carefully about
how you might compare something
less favorable first.
A different option, knowing
that in this information
overloaded world
where we seek to make
quick and efficient decisions.
That's a small
change you can make
that leads to a big difference.
But here's a mistake
we often make.
When we're presenting proposals.
When we're thinking about
how we might craft our case,
we'll come up with lots
of different options
that we're about to
present, and then
discard those that are
perhaps not the optimum
And we'll focus
on just one option
and throw away those options
that perhaps aren't optimal.
And it turns out that
can be a mistake.
In the same way as
when you were at school
you'd get extra marks for
showing not only how you've
got to the math answer, but
how you actually-- not just the
answer itself, but how you
actually got to the answer.
The same is true of
influence and persuasion.
Anything you could do
in the early stages
of your proposition,
your proposals,
to point out options that
you all going to discard
increases the salience and
the attractiveness of the very
next thing that you
actually present.
It works in negotiations too.
I've a wonderful
set of studies here
that simply show that going
first in a negotiation
tends to be the
optimum thing to do.
We have lots of
questions sometimes
from people that
say, well, if I'm
going to go into a
negotiation, is it better
for me to sit back and
wait for that opponent
to make their first
offer, or is it better
actually if I make the
first offer myself?
And the answer is,
clearly, the latter.
In these studies, for example,
negotiators purchasing
quite a large scale
industrial units here,
we find that those
buyers that presented
their option, their price
first, typically came away
with about $5 million
increased value
compared to those that actually
waited for the opponents
to make the first offer.
So there's a key thing here--
the key theme rather here
about this idea of
what you present
first matters an
awful lot when it
comes to influence
and persuasion.
Let's talk about the second
of these motivations.
Our desire to
affiliate with others.
To make decisions
and behave in ways
that gain the
approval of others.
Before we talk about
some of the examples
from persuasion science, I think
it's important at this point
to mention a dark side,
a downside to this idea
of affiliating and behaving
in the way that others do.
One of the things we know
from extensive research
on this idea of social
norms, that people follow
what many others are doing, is
that it doesn't discriminate
between desirable and
undesirable behaviors.
If we see that many
people are behaving
in ways that are
undesirable, are less
productive to the organization,
we could often join them,
and we can often find that those
unwanted behaviors increase
further.
There's a really good example
from here in the United States.
In 2007 the Inland
Revenue Services
doubled the fine for the
late submission of taxes
from $100 to $200.
And the reason that the IRS gave
for that doubling of the fine
was because the previous year,
so many American citizens
had failed to submit
their tax returns on time.
So in an attempt to motivate
people to submit their tax
returns on time, they
doubled the fine.
The next year there was a 22%
increase in late submissions.
It's almost as if
people are saying,
well, if everyone
else is doing it,
then maybe I should do it too.
And this is an
important consideration
when you think about trying to
change behaviors, particularly
less desirable behaviors in
organizations and in societies.
Often leaders will make the
mistake of drawing attention
to regrettably, frequent,
undesirable behaviors,
and in doing so actually serve
to increase their frequency.
AUDIENCE: Just say no to drugs.
STEVE: One of my
favorite examples
concerns the National Petrified
Forest Park in Arizona
here in the United States.
Visitors would come up to the
gate and they would see a sign.
Designed to reduce the
theft of petrified wood
in crystals from
the forest floor
that they were losing
some 14 tons of per year.
And the sign would say, "Your
heritage is being lost."
Vandalized if you
like, by the theft
of small pieces of crystal
and petrified wood.
Last year we lost 14 tons.
People were coming up to the
gate, looking at the sign,
and thinking, we better
get ours quick, then.
It wasn't a crime
prevention strategy.
It was a crime
promotion strategy.
So so much better if you want
to influence and persuade
effectively using this
core motivation to point
to behaviors that are
desirable in a given situation.
Now my two co-authors, Noah
Goldstein and Robert Cialdini,
gained some notoriety a few
years ago for a set of studies
concerning these small
cards that you'll often
find in hotel bathrooms.
Have you seen these?
This card here, this
is one from the hotel
that we're staying
at this weekend.
"Help us save the planet.
It's time for us to take part
in helping the environment.
Please re-use your towels
by hanging them on the rack
as a signal that
you want to play
your part for the environment."
Turns out there's a much,
much more effective way
of getting people to reuse
there towels and linens, which
concerns changing the
words on this card
to instead of
saying, please do it
for the sake of the
environment, to instead say,
did you know that
significant numbers of people
who stay in our hotel do
reuse their towels and linens?
That simple message of
affiliating and aligning
the message to gain
the approval of others
typically increases
towel reuse by about 26%.
That's a pretty big difference
for such a small change.
Now consider this
for a few moments.
If you want to
check into a hotel,
and see one of those little
cards to the bathroom
and it says the
following message,
just consider for a few moments
what your first reaction would
be if when you
picked up the card
you read a message
that said, dear guest,
did you know that the person
that stayed in this room
before you reused their
towels and linens.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE: Yeah, the first
thing you're going to think
is, I hope they're
not the same towels.
No one wants to know what the
person who stayed in that hotel
room before you
got up to or did.
As far as we're concerned,
we're the first person
to have ever stayed
in that room.
And so interestingly,
people will typically
dismiss that message,
that persuasive appeal
as having no relevance at all.
It will have no effect.
But interestingly, in
Noah and Bob's studies,
when they changed
that message to say,
dear guest, the
majority of people
that stayed in this room, 107,
416, 921, reused their towel,
it was the single
most effective message
of all, which demonstrates
a really interesting quirk
in terms of persuasion science.
This idea that
we're oftentimes not
that good at actually
recognizing what
does influence and persuade us.
And to give a demonstration,
those towels studies
spawned a subsequent
set of research
that we were engaged in when
it came to persuading people
to pay their taxes on time.
Take a look at this.
The UK government typically
would send out letters saying,
please, submit your tax
return by this date.
Pay this amount.
If you fail to do so by the
schedule dates on this letter
there will be a fine.
The fine is 100 pounds.
It's about $160.
And they typically would
get a response rate at here,
you can see about 68%,
within a given time.
We made one small
change to that letter
by placing a sentence across
the top that simply said,
truthfully, that the
majority of people
do pay their taxes on time.
And when we did
that we registered
a pretty impressive
increase in response rates.
OK.
We didn't stop there.
We went one stage
further and said,
well, if people are more likely
to reuse their towels if they
know that the person
to stay in the room
before them reused that towels,
would people be even more
likely to respond to the
request to submit their tax
returns on time if they're told
what the majority of people
in the UK doing, but the
majority of people in their zip
code, in that postal code.
And the answer was, yes.
A further impressive increase.
And when we add the name of
the town, Mountain View, San
Francisco, Tempe, Arizona, and
key into that social identity
we get a huge increase.
That's an 83% response rate.
If you needed anymore
convincing of the power
of these small changes linked to
these deep seated motivations,
this is the set
of data to provide
that clarity, that evidence.
Because the Inland Revenue
Services in the United Kingdom
have collected literally
hundreds of millions
of additional dollars
in tax revenues
by simply aligning
their message,
their persuasive appeal
to this core motivation.
Talk about the final one.
This idea that we
want to act in ways
that allow us to see
ourselves in a positive light.
That's why the
majority of people
think that they're an
above average driver.
It's also the reason why after
our sports team has perhaps
played particularly
badly one weekend
we'll talk about how
badly they played,
but after an
impressive win we'll
talk about how
brilliantly we played.
This idea of how we
want to act in ways
that allow us to feel that we
are seen positively by others.
This idea of a self commitment.
Let me give you a
couple of examples.
Adam Grate, who's a
professor here a Wharton,
published an interesting set of
studies just a couple of years
ago.
How do you arrange and
persuade doctors, physicians
to sanitize their hands, to
wash their hands each time
that they go onto a
hospital ward, or each time
they go into a treatment
room, or each time they
treat an individual patient.
They tested three
different messages.
The first was a simple,
gel in, wash out.
An information appeal.
Had no effect
whatsoever at increasing
this practice of
hand sanitization.
So they tried to second message.
And it was to say,
it's important
that you wash your hands
because it keeps you sanitized.
It keeps you healthy.
You do it for the
benefit of you.
No effect whatsoever.
It was the first
message, the message
that said, please,
wash your hands.
Please, sanitize your hands
for the sake of your patients.
It was this idea
that they were almost
being reminded of the
commitment that they
had made when they qualified
as medical practitioners.
So what small
changes could we key
into there that might
lead to big differences?
Well, take a look at this.
Is a really interesting
set of research
that looks at the simple act of
including someone's photograph
on their x-rays
and their CT scans.
Now imagine you're
a diagnosing doctor.
You see lots of plates, lots
of CT scans, lots of x-rays.
And your job is to diagnose
them and make a recommendation.
The small change here
was to simply include
a photograph of that
patient on their x-ray plate
to humanize the situation in the
context, and in that instance
a significant increase in the
amount of treatment options
and rated caring that those
physicians employed and applied
to those x-ray plates.
So one way that we can
increase people's likelihood
to be seen in a
positive light is
to do things that
humanize interactions
and remind them of
their commitments.
Here's another.
You'll probably recognize
from the accent,
I'm not from these parts.
I'm from the United Kingdom.
The UK National Health Service
has a significant problem
with the number of people
that will make appointments
to go to see a physician, a
physiotherapist, a dentist,
and fail to show up.
We have a system that is free at
the point of delivery as well.
So there are no
penalties or costs
incurred if patients
fail to turn up.
All the expense, all the cost,
all those wasted resources
is borne by the
National Health System.
It costs literally
hundreds of millions
of pounds each and every year.
800 million pounds
at the last estimate.
How might we use one of
these core motivations
to change the way that an
interaction takes place that
increases the likelihood
that people will show up?
Well, here's one change
that we actually made.
When people phoned for an
appointment, rather than
the receptionist simply put the
phone down after that patient
to be given the time, and
day of their appointment,
they will pause and ask
simply that individual
to repeat back verbally the
time and day of the appointment.
"Your requirement is at
Tuesday next at 2:30.
Could you just confirm
that for me please?"
Wait for the patient
to confirm it,
and we registered a modest, but
still significant reduction.
A 3 1/2% reduction, but a 3
1/2% reduction of an 800 hundred
million pound problem. that's
like a $1.3 billion problem is
still significant.
We then actually
tested another insight,
which made to the
commitment even more active.
How many of you when you've
been given an appointment
at a doctor's, or dentist's,
or a physiotherapist have ever
been given a little
card with the time
and day the appointment?
Most of you in the room
is being given that.
OK.
Who writes the
details on the card?
AUDIENCE: The receptionist.
STEVE: Yeah, yes,
the receptionist.
It's the health
clerk, the person
who is make an
appointment for you.
Turns out that there
is very good evidence
that that is the wrong person.
OK?
When we simply rearranged for
the blank card and the pen
to be given to the
individual, we now
register a very
impressive reduction close
to 18% reduction in no shows.
Now an 18% reduction in
a $1.3 billion problem.
That's a huge impact
for such a small change.
So what I sought to have
done this afternoon,
in our short time together, is
to offer you an additional way
to think about
influence and persuasion
beyond the traditional
information, education,
and economic levers
that we typically
rely on to persuade others.
And that's to align your
request to just a set
of very small, but deeply rooted
motivations that we all have,
and that we all
deem as important.
The importance
and the motivation
to make rapid,
efficient decisions
in a crazy information
overloaded world.
The motivation to
make those decisions
in a way that align,
and affiliate,
and gain the approval of others.
And to make those
decisions in a way that
allow us to be seen publicly
in a positive light.
And notice a couple of things
about these small changes.
First, that they often required
just a change in context,
not necessary a
change in cognition.
Or a shift in the fundamental
strategy or persuasion
appeal that you're
making of someone.
We're not necessarily
asking you to change
what you have, change
what you offer,
change what you're proposing.
Just change the context
in which it's seen.
That's the first.
The second, notice how
small these changes are.
Rarely, this is a
surprising aspects
of this recent and growing
body of persuasion research
is that rarely do they require
costly investments in time,
in money, in
additional resources.
And finally notice that
rarely do these insights
come about by an
investigation of the best
practices within
an organization.
And the best evidence
I can give for that
is the data from
the tax offices.
Tax officials have
been collecting
your money, our
money, for centuries.
You would have thought that
they would have figured
out the most effective
ways to do it.
They figured out
the best practices.
And I'm a big fan of
sharing best practice,
but remember also that best
practices do have a limitation.
And the limitation being that
they'll typically only uncover
those best practices
that are, and insights
that are already known.
It took a team of persuasion
scientists to figure out
there was a more
effective way as well.
So I wonder how
we're doing for time.
We just got maybe a
couple of moments.
So I just did want
to just finish off
with this, this question here.
This idea of will these
effects work in combination?
And will they work
in any context,
or are there
limitations to them?
And I think that there
are limitations to them.
So I don't want to
present a panacea here
that this is the way to
influence and persuade people
every time, but
rather just offer
a set of universal
principles and rules
that will guide you to a
more effective outcome.
But let me just talk
briefly about a couple
of these some recent studies
that we sight in the book.
The first is a good
friend of mine,
Paul Dolan, who is a behavioral
economist at the London
School of Economics, ran
a really interesting set
of experiments recently.
He found that if you send a
letter to homeowners telling
them that they
are consuming more
energy than their
neighbors with a request
to reduce their
energy consumption,
that's a pretty effective way
of actually getting people
to reduce their
energy consumption.
You use that peer pressure.
And in Paul's
studies, he typically
found that there was about a 6%
reduction in energy consumption
the following month.
He also found,
interestingly, that if you
send a letter to
people and say, please
reduce your energy
consumption, and if you do,
we'll give you $150, that that
was pretty effective as well,
typically reducing
energy consumption
by about the same amount.
So the question,
of course, is, what
if we combine those two things?
What if we send a
letter to people
that says, please reduce
your energy consumption
and fall in line with your
neighbors, and if you do,
we'll pay you $150?
It turns out that when Paul
did that in his studies,
people had a heating party.
Now in mathematics,
1 plus 1 equals 2.
In persuasion science,
that's not always the case.
So I can't report that simply
adding more persuasion tactics
to an appeal would actually
lead to be more effective.
Oftentimes, it doesn't.
It actually reduces its
effects, much in the same way
as if you pour all of the
spice from your spice racks
into the chicken, no one
is going to want eat it.
I think it's the same when it
comes to persuasion as well.
Here's another example.
Back to our friend Adam
Grant from Wharton,
a series of studies looking
at charitable fund raising
appeals.
He found that, again, a similar
approach, when people were sent
a letter saying, please
donate to this charity,
and there was an appeal that
targeted their ego, think
about what others will be saying
about you if you do donate,
that was a pretty
effective appeal.
They raised donations
as a result.
A second group got
a different letter,
a more altruistic approach.
Think the benefit you'll
do to others by donating.
That was pretty
effective as well.
And he found the same thing when
he combined the two approaches.
Put that egotistical and
altruistic effects together,
and it canceled out the effect.
So the key message here is to
use these insights sparingly.
They are small.
They fly under the radar.
And what we're
finding is that if we
try to incorporate too many,
we do build resistance.
One final one, and I think
this speaks to the environment
that we're here in in Google
as well, is this idea of, well,
do they work equally effectively
in different contexts,
for example, online?
This is a series of studies that
we conducted with our friends
at Blue State Digital--
again, fund raising.
We send out emails
to people asking
to donate to a
particular charity
and test different messages.
And one of the messages
we wanted to test
was this idea of to
gain the approval
and to affiliate with
others, so pointing out
how previous people like them
had donated to the appeal.
And we sent those out
by email and found
it had no effect whatsoever,
no effect at all.
And we think what's
going on here
is that oftentimes that more
bloodless communication,
that email wasn't surveying to
humanize that communication as
much.
It turned out that the best
message in an email environment
was to simply tell people
how easy it was to donate.
It only takes a minute.
And that seems to
be the best message
for that context for that
communication channel.
And that's where we get this
significant increase as well.
So leave you with
the thought that
oftentimes these
small changes, we also
need to think about the
appropriate context in which
they could be used as well.
But the fact of the matter
is that they are all small.
And it turns out
that when it comes
to influencing and
persuading others,
I think we're gathering more
and more evidence that small
can very much be the new big.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARIS: Tell a
little story there.
I know people here are
with PG&E. We are at home
and we get these
letters that say
how our neighbors are doing.
And certainly, that was like,
almost like a game for us,
and we were way
over our neighbors.
And so, I felt really bad,
and so then we adjusted.
STEVE: Yeah, I
think it's the case
that the US, through
the Opower Organization,
have made great
strides in that field,
those home energy reports.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious if
you could hazard a guess as
to a couple generations
down the road.
We learn a couple of, sort
of, small changes we can make.
Do you think as
generations progressed,
we become as a group, become
more immune to things?
So then these kind of things
will have to be repeated?
Or is it intrinsic in
our nature some how?
STEVE: Yeah, that's
a great question.
AUDIENCE: The
desensitization as a--
STEVE: Yeah, as we learn more
about the influence process
and learn more about the
strategies that do effectively
influence and
persuade others, do
we become less affected by
them, and perhaps desensitized
to them?
So I want to say two
things about that.
I think the first
thing to recognize
is that it's not just our
knowledge of the influence
and persuasion process that
extends and grows over time.
Our knowledge of all information
extends and grows as well.
So it's not that we are
growing in our insights
about one particular field
to the expense of others.
So we are constantly
being overloaded.
So our need to have quick and
efficient mechanisms for making
decisions won't
wane, if anything,
it will actually increase.
But I think there
is a case to be
made when it comes to
the particular tactic
or individual strategy
that someone uses.
I'll give you an example.
So it turns out
that if you've ever
been given a mint or
a chocolate at the end
if your meal when the
food server brings
the receipt and the
bill along for you,
despite people saying that they
are immune to such effects,
it does-- there's one.
It does influence
tipping behavior.
So if a food server puts
down one mint for each person
at the table along
with the bill,
tips typically increase
in these studies
that David Strohmetz
conducted, by around about 3%.
Interesting, if they put
two mints down on the table,
they don't double.
They actually quadrupole.
You get about a 14% increase.
So there's a really
good example of us
responding to an obligation.
Someone's given
that to us first.
Now if every single
restaurant did that,
we would very,
very quickly become
desensitized to that
particular tactic.
And therefore, I
think you would wane.
It would decrease in
effectiveness pretty rapidly.
But the fundamental
motive that drives
that behavior, our
desire to give back
to others what has been given
to us first and to live up
or obligations, that
doesn't wane at all.
So I think the answer
to your question
is that the
individual strategies
and tactics themselves
could become less effective
over time, but the
fundamental set
of principles that shape and
guide influence and persuasion
will increase in value as
we become more information
overloaded, more stimulus
saturated, and require
these shortcuts
to good decisions.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that context
is more powerful
than information
or economic reasons, and then
delivering this message to us
or persuade with us, could
you use context in addition
to all the information you
give out as an example to us?
STEVE: Well, that's
exactly right.
Now I'm not saying that
information, and education,
and incentives aren't important.
They are very, very important.
But consider them--
consider them like this.
Consider them like
two legs of a stool.
Two legged stools
are often wobbly.
What this set of research
presents and offers
is a third stabilizing
leg, a third lever.
and this thing
about information.
It's great that we have access
to just so much information,
easily accessible at
the click of a button,
the swipe of a screen.
You are, as an organization,
the world's curators
when it comes to
information, and I
think that's an actual
wonderful thing.
But remember too
that we are just
overwhelmed with information.
Just simply pouring more
information into an appeal
is much like pouring more
water into an already full pail
of water.
It'll just spill
out over the sides.
And so it's not information
the influences us.
Its information in
the right context
that aligns to one of
these core motivations.
That, I think, is the key
to successful persuasion.
It provides that additional
set of tools in that regard.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any more examples
of some interesting
situations where
like AB testing
might be effective.
Specifically in our marketing
and our advertising at Google
where an AB test,
the presentation
might make the difference
between the sale
of-- the purchase of
an ad space versus not,
or something like that?
STEVE: Yeah, I do.
And do you know I think you're
just in a wonderful position
to be able to do that with the
facilities you actually have.
To craft an appeal, and just
make a small, subtle change
to maybe the position of
an image on a website,
or the inclusion of a
social proof appeal,
or the change in words.
I mean that's
essentially what we
did with those
charitable studies.
We randomize three
different audiences
to receive a different message.
Took 10% of the
total audience that
were going to
receive these emails.
Figured out which one
was the most effective,
so that we can then load all
the ballast onto the 90% that
haven't yet received the email.
I'm a huge fan of this
idea of test and learn.
And one of the things that
new technologies give us now
is the ability do that
very quickly, very simply,
often very, very cheaply.
AUDIENCE: Electronics is cheap.
STEVE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Electronics is cheep.
It isn't paper.
It doesn't live forever.
STEVE: Yeah.
Yeah, we're in this
position now where
we can test and learn
a lot more effectively.
Do so on a small scale,
but a big enough scale
to recognize there are some
robustness to what we're
actually doing, and
then we could, as I say,
load our resources on that
message or that appeal
that we know is tested the best.
AUDIENCE: You provided a number
of examples about big things
that were done.
Affecting a lot of people.
Taxpayers, guests in hotels.
Do you have examples
of things that you've
done for one on one
interactions with other people
where this comes into play?
STEVE: Yeah.
Yeah, let me give you a couple
of those, because, yeah, I
think when we're talking
about these big data sets,
large numbers of
homogeneous transactions
allow us to be able to present
a compelling case in terms
of the robustness.
But oftentimes our
influence appeals
are simply down to a
one to one interaction
with a colleague or a manager.
So let me give you a couple.
There's one that actually
we talk about in the book.
A series of studies conducted
by Terri Kurtzberg from Rutgers
University over
in New Jersey, who
finds that when we
are looking to build
a relationship with
someone who is remote
to us, a colleague perhaps
in a different city
or even in a different region
of the world, something
we can do very, very early
on in our email exchanges
to humanize that
interaction is to place
an attachment, such
a small cartoon.
So she conducted this with
one to one negotiations
in organizations and found that
when the individual concerned
reached out to a negotiating
partner in their organization--
and in this instance, actually
attached a Dilbert cartoon,
where Dilbert actually screws
up a negotiation-- that
was the kind of ice breaker.
So in an increasingly electronic
world we actually live in,
these small steps that just
humanize an interaction
could be important things that
make the difference to everyone
else that's doing the quick,
efficient email thing.
So there is an immediate
example in a one to one
situation reaching
out to colleagues.
AUDIENCE: So that's an example
of changing the context.
STEVE: Yes, I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
It gives a sense of there's
someone on the other side,
not just perhaps a
faceless email address.
It humanizes that interaction.
AUDIENCE: How can you guard
against these techniques being
used on you?
Because sometimes I
mean, these techniques
can be used in a good way
and also in a bad way.
So is it like just by knowing
these techniques it-selves,
is it enough to
guard against them?
STEVE: Yeah, I mean
that's a great question.
In fact, there's an inherent
message underneath that
as well, which is that
some of these effects
can be used to exploit, to
manipulate, to get people
perhaps to make decisions
that they wouldn't ordinarily
make if they had all the
facts or all the information
to actually have.
So there's a very important
ethical message here.
That one would hope that you'd
only use these in a morally,
responsible, and ethical way.
I think that understanding
these biases,
understanding how they do affect
and influence us can help.
So one could make the argument
that any book about influence
and persuasion, or any set of
information about the influence
and persuasion process is
not only a set of tools
to influence and
persuade others,
but arguably could be used as
a defense strategy as well.
I'm not entirely convinced
that knowing these effects
is going to be enough.
And the primary reason
for that is that we just
don't have oftentimes
the space to think about
whether they are
being used on us.
And I'm particularly
these small changes
that are so small they
often fly under the radar.
There is very good evidence
from the persuasion sciences
and behavioral sciences,
more generally,
that people aren't that
good at recognizing
what it is in a context that
does influence and persuade
them.
There's a really
great set of studies
that were conducted
here in California.
When researchers
went door to door
asking homeowners which
message would most
motivate them to reduce
their energy consumption.
Perhaps be a little bit more
environmentally friendly.
They rated information about how
if they change their behavior
it would be
beneficial to society
as the biggest
motivation, followed
by the impact of having
future generations,
followed by the savings
they'd actually make.
They dismissed the idea
that because their neighbors
were increasingly
making these changes
that it would have
any influence.
But then, in the tests,
when those messages
were distributed across the
neighbors, the neighborhoods
rather, that message
of social proof
was the only message
that had an effect.
So it's a really good
demonstration of much
as it might not be
comforting to learn,
we often aren't that
good at recognizing
what does influence
and persuade us.
So I'm not entirely
convinced that
just learning about
them will be enough.
But I think it's a good step.
AUDIENCE: More and
more I think about it,
my takeaway is that
you don't really
know what is actually
going to work.
And it depends on the context,
depends on the people.
The same message may not
work in a different crowd.
So if you just had one chance,
then almost, you could try,
but you don't know what
the effect is going to be.
But if you were able
to do some testing,
and so on, and try
different options then
you have a possibility
like the AB testing
where you could do 1%, 2%, and
then go for a larger message.
But like the presentations
and so on, you have one shot.
Where you're talking to a VP and
saying, hey, here's the thing.
You could deploy the strategy
which you talked about,
hey, use two of these.
You don't really
know what the effect
is going to be ultimately.
STEVE: Well, I do except
that to a certain point.
However, I do
think that there is
a huge advantage
to understanding
the fundamental principles
compared to perhaps just going
with gut feeling.
Yeah?
And if we know that
we can increase
the appeal, the effectiveness
of our proposition,
by aligning it to one or more
of these core motivations,
and that we will be
in a better position
than not, that alone has
got to be of huge value
compared to sitting at our desks
with the spreadsheet in front
of us, the slideshow,
whatever it may be,
thinking about, well, what do
I think will influence this VP?
There's a set of tools
grounded in good evidence that
will increase potentially
the likelihood that we
will be successful.
I'm never going to say, and any
person that comes into Google
and says that they found the
way to persuade 100% of people
100% of the time, you want
to kick them out the door.
Because it doesn't exist.
But we can, by making
these small changes,
measure bigger affects in
our persuasive success.
There's no doubt about that.
AUDIENCE: Got a question on
just more personal as far as you
writing this book.
What was your
process involved in
like finding time for
yourself to get this done?
STEVE: Yeah.
And there's three of
us, by the way, as well.
It's not just my book.
Noah Goldstein and
Robert Cialdini
have also contributed equally.
So one thing that has
helped is the fact
that we've structured this
book slightly differently
to a traditional book,
which would have maybe
a core idea and then
eight or nine chapters
that it expands on.
This book is made up of
actually 53 chapters,
and each chapter is no
more than 1,500 words long.
So it presents an insight
from persuasion science,
it gives you enough of
the underlying mechanism
to get in touch with
what's actually going on,
and then it rapidly
moves to a, here's
what it means to you
at work, at home,
whatever the situation may be.
And so writing them
in that way, I think,
was a good exercise,
because we could write them
as perhaps blog
posts to begin with.
500 or 600 word blog posts.
Scan the latest research, read
the abstracts in the journals,
pick those that we think have
a good basis of application,
and then extend those chapters.
So we could write them
at different times.
And we don't necessarily have
to write them sequentially,
one after the other.
We could write them as the
data becomes available,
and then think about
the application.
So that's one of the
approaches we actually made,
and that made the
job a lot easier.
Of course, the challenge
then is just when
you've got lots
and lots of content
is how you actually organize it.
And that's where this idea of
these three core motivations
came in.
That we could generally
categorized them.
And that's the approach
we actually took.
I think the final
thing which was useful,
was the fact that-- so I'm
not an academic by training.
My two colleagues clearly are.
And so to have that balance of
scientifically and academically
informed insights, but
then a reality check
that said, OK, well, that's
all very well in theory,
but how do you
apply in practice?
What does that mean to people in
Google, people in organizations
that need to interact
each and every day?
How do we operationalize this?
I think that was also
an important aspect
of the creation process too.
Well, thank you
very much indeed.
[APPLAUSE]